Mexican senol cartel's message to
members stop making fentol or Die the
senol cartel known for exporting fentol
to the US has ordered a halt to product
fentol production and and trafficking
within its territory driven by pressure
by from US law enforcement the directive
is attributed to uh uh uh chapito led by
wakin El Chapo Guzman's Sons uh uh the
Biden Administration Administration has
been urging Mexico to take aggressive
step to dismantle the cartel which is a
major fentol trafficking group us deaths
from fentol have become a political
issue with calls from some Republicans
to send US military to Mexico to battle
to combat fentol trafficking some
individuals in Seno have faced violence
and death for defying the ban While
others are reluctant to shut down their
operations due to strong demand for
fentol in the US so can you imagine the
Mexican senal La cartel is say stop
making it that's a Feelgood story that's
murderers with moral morals that's a
murderers with morals but that's the
Italian mop story right hey we don't do
drugs we don't do this we don't do that
if you do it we're going to take you out
and if you did do it you got in trouble
although a lot of people ended up doing
it yeah so it when it's that profitable
you're going to do it go ahead Tom
there's a great scene in The Godfather
where where movies sort of give us a
window into reality and it's when Marlon
Brando says he did not want the drugs
and he called gambling prostitution
harmless vices remember the speech he
gives and he says I'm not in favor of
the drugs he's talking Salo right I'm
not in favor of the drug thing he says
but harmless VI I'm at you know you
don't know whether this is window
dressing or whether these guys are
looking saying listen you know next year
there's a an election and a feel-good
story for the Americans in the election
is they sent a couple Apache helicopters
over here and they take out my house so
you guys better knock it off and as a
matter of fact maybe I need to knock off
a few lowlevel guys to make this look
good is it that way that they're really
they're they're doing it and they're
supported by China and they're doing it
anyway but they're running a PR campaign
where a couple low-level drug dealers
get knocked you know get hit and they
make it look like they're trying to tow
the line because they do not want the US
military to come in there we did a very
good job did you hear what you just said
go back and repeat what you just said
they don't want the US military go back
a story prior to that do they did they
knock off a couple of them to make it
look good as a PR campaign
exactly ex do you understand was saying
ago so that's the part to give
permission to be like so that's the part
why you ought to consider that as a
possibility even though if it's a one or
2% so there's a part of me that reads
this story and thinks it's the the
cartel's public PR firm is a strong PR
firm can you imagine yeah we represent
the cartels the Mexican Calo cartel in
New York it's a one of the biggest PR
firms you buron Marell are here the
largest PR firm in the United States and
we now our portfolio includes by there's
this is not a time for jokes but I
remember there was a long ago there was
a a mockery that was done
because they invaded this this Major
Distribution place that was in um
Colombia that was wrapping it all up and
there was this room where you saw these
pictures and the boxes of these ziplock
freezer bags there was like 50,000 boxes
of these ziplock freezer bags in there
and so it says some salesman at the Glad
ziplock he says really made quota on
these guys who's one of your bigger
customers well you know the cartel on
there they need the one pound freezer
bags for the cocaine and boy I got that
pool in my backyard because I cut the
deal so ziplock could have given them
some Intel of where they're buying where
they're shipping these bags to get more
information out Adam give final thought
talking about a PR campaign it's
essentially a PR campaign or even
propaganda is to give the illusion or
the facade that you're doing one thing
when you're actually kind of doing
another or to sort of um expound upon
what the greatness is but you maybe sort
of mitigate what the thing is if don't
don't look now but what is Joe Biden
doing because this article right here
basically says the Biden Administration
has been urging Mexico to take
aggressive steps to dismantle the caloa
cartel the major fentol trafficking
group okay boom what are we seeing
lowkey from Joe Biden these days well
he's kind of building a little bit of a
wall yeah not sure if you noticed kind
of talk about that he's clearly taking a
hard line with Mexico lowkey so what's
the pr what's the facade listen we love
immigrants we love all that but lowkey
he's trying to play tough with Mexico
you know what he's doing he's realizing
everything all the policies Trump had
were successful so let me replicate
those policies without being too loud
about it because if God forbid people
find that it's their policies I'm going
to be in trouble because they're
duplicating what he's doing so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here